those in favor say aye aye
with one voice they shared a damning
conclusion
this Congressional committee had brought
us Insurrection and inside story
in the end it pointed the finger at its
principal actor I don't want to say the
elections are but I just want to say
Congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
Donald Trump they said should be charged
with at least four offenses including
inciting or assisting an insurrection
the president has an affirmative and
primary constitutional duty to act to
take care that the laws be Faithfully
executed nothing could be a greater
betrayal of this Duty than to assist in
Insurrection against the Constitutional
order
tax committee hearings had used evidence
previously unseen and unheard to paint a
picture of the violence and Chaos that
was January the 6th
and there was testimony from the team
around Trump they spoke of his claims of
a rigged election they made it clear I
did not agree with the idea of saying
the election was stolen and putting out
this stuff which I told the president
there was on the day encouragement to
the mall we fight like hell and if you
don't fight like hell you're not going
to have a country anymore
[Music]
it was little sympathy as writers
Chantry to hang Mike Pence as the vice
president tried to certify the election
for Joe Biden Mark had responded
something to the effect of you heard of
Pat he thinks Mike deserves it he
doesn't think they're doing anything
wrong
this committee has put Donald Trump
firmly in the frame if not in the dock
it's not for them to press charges
they're politicians that's beyond their
power but the recommendations have gone
to this country's Department of Justice
he is unfit for any office Trump's
initial response was for the committee
Vice chairless Cheney a reminder of her
40-point defeat in a Republican primary
election
it's all politics for now